faut quand même voir dans quelle
situation vous êtes c'est-à-dire que
vous êtes très bien et vous demandez
qu'on vous enlève les seins parce que
vous savez que vous allez inexorablement
être victime d'un cancer du sein
on nous accueillons notre terrien du
samedi 20h ce soir Laetitia Mendes
bonsoir
Laetitia Mendes en 2013 Angelina Jolie
annonce qu'elle s'est fait enlever les
deux un elle est en effet porteuse d'une
mutation génétique qui a 80% provoque un
cancer du sein cette histoire Laetitia
vous l'avez vécu en 2004 à 24 ans comme
Angelina vous apprenez que vous êtes
porteuse de ce gène qui a déjà touché
votre mère et votre grand-mère et vous
aussi vous choisissez l'ablation
préventive des deux saints
alors votre histoire Laetitia vous la
racontez dans un livre publié chez Anne
Carrière intitulé Mon petit jeune ma
seconde chance et à 20h donc Salut les
Terriens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'elle a poussé à ce moment-là en
touchant sa poitrine et en découvrant
qu'on n'a pas reconstruit ses seins
c'est le cri que moi je ressens au fond
de la mienne en fait
7 ans elle tentera trois reconstructions
sans grand succès mais surtout elle
mènera une véritable croisade en faveur
du dépistage du gène BRCA donc est à
l'origine de ces cancers héréditaires
exactement alors là l'angoisse s'empare
de vous vous demandez est-ce que je suis
moi-même porteuse du jeune BRCA vous
êtes complètement flippé avant de faire
le test
vous savez que vous avez deux chances
sur 10 de vous en sortir exactement et
en même temps au moment où je le fais
j'ai l'intime conviction que j'ai déjà
la réponse et que je sais que je suis
déjà si je ne fais pas ce qu'il faut
pour condamner moi aussi et là vous
demandez l'ablation préventive il faut
quand même voir dans quelle situation
vous êtes c'est-à-dire que vous êtes
très bien et vous demandez qu'on vous
enlève les seins parce que vous savez
que vous allez inexorablement être
victime d'un cancer du sein vous avez 24
ans à l'époque et on me regarde avec des
yeux comme ça
à l'époque en France enlever des parties
saines d'un corps c'est encore tabou les
médecins rechignent à faire ça et là
vous êtes enceinte c'est presque le
break qui fallait à ce moment-là parce
que je comprends que cette naissance en
plus l'avantage c'est que ma maman a
aussi rencontré ma petite fille avant de
disparaître donc je sais que c'est le
seul c'est la seule que je vais avoir et
mais c'est ce qui me motive davantage et
qui me rend plus déterminé que jamais
dès que j'ai dès que j'ai mis cette
enfant au monde vous êtes enceinte
j'espère que ce sera un garçon je dirais
pas malheureusement mais enfin c'est une
fille Lana finalement après des
démarches particulièrement long on garde
c'est pas un médecin qui décide c'est un
collège de médecin vous obtenez de subir
l'ablation des deux saints ce qui
réduira vos chances de cancer du sein de
90 à 5%. exactement j'obtiens gain de
cause alors vous êtes donc la première
femme en France a subir une double
mastectomie préventive et le chirurgien
vous pose deux implants directement mais
le pire est à venir on peut dire parce
que à peine rentré chez vous vous
découvrez que vous ne supportez plus le
regard de votre mari sur votre peau vous
dites cette phrase terrible vous dites
il y a une incompatibilité esthétique
entre nous car lui là c'est beau il a un
corps de rêve et vous vous êtes là avec
vos cicatrices
qui ne colle plus avec l'image que j'ai
toujours renvoyé j'ai énormément de mal
à me reconnecter à moi à ma féminité
c'est
c'est très dur et un an plus tard le
couple vole en éclat oui alors vos
prothèses vous posent en plus des
problèmes vous avez l'impression de vous
trimballer avec deux aquariums
complètement c'est horrible et alors
plus grave finalement c'est quand vous
serrez votre fille contre vous vous
sentez rien quoi c'est un torse engourdi
comme quand on a les fourmis un peu
comme les gens voilà
vraiment plus rien donc le toucher la
sensibilité tout ça c'est c'est très
très dur à très difficile parce que
quand vous avez rendez-vous vous avez un
rendez-vous avec un mec vous dites c'est
comme aller à sa première boum avec un
herpès sur les lèvres bah on a
l'impression que tout le monde le voit
en plus on a l'impression que comme on
n'est pas bien dans ses baskets c'est
quelque chose qui fonctionne pas alors
heureusement vous avez rencontré un mec
le tatoueur un petit brun qui va vous
reconnecter à la vie il fait beaucoup il
a beaucoup œuvré en ce sens et c'est
très très important lorsque
vous découvrez que vos implants
mammaires sont des pays c'est-à-dire les
implants mammaires du du célèbre escroc
qui j'espère est en prison pour
longtemps Jean-Claude masse
alors là vous devez repasser sur le
billard alors là bon peu à peu vous
sentez mieux mais là bon comme vous êtes
une fille active vous faites des séances
de sport de danse vous prenez des avions
alors que c'est pas recommandé vous
allez à Las Vegas vous vous sentez
invincible jusqu'au jour où l'une des
prothèses tournent alors ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est quand les protestes
tournent les chers se figent autour de
la prothèse et donc vous allez voir le
docteur Fitoussi qui essaie de de vous
remettre la prothèse dans le bon sens
mais malheureusement les chers se sont
figés autour de la prothèse il y a rien
à faire il faut une troisième opération
il a ce qui est assez extraordinaire je
dois dire c'est que vous le faites
vous-même ce que vous rentrez chez vous
vous enfermez dans les toilettes vous
accroupissez vous remettez votre
prothèse d'aplomb au risque d'arracher
les chairs qui sont figés autour c'est
extrêmement courageux il était hors de
question que je repasse sur le lien j'en
étais pas capable à ce moment là et puis
le 14 mai 201 3 Angelina Jolie
révèle qu'elle vient de se faire enlever
ces deux seins car les porteuses de
cette mutation génétique qu'on appelle
le BRCA et là ça vous libère donc vous
décidez d'écrire ce livre
c'est exactement ça ce qui vous inquiète
aujourd'hui le plus c'est que votre sœur
Audrey refuse de le faire mais vous
savez on sait qu'un jour ou l'autre elle
aura un cancer du sein est-ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est qu'on a beau se faire faire
des mamos et tout ça ce cancer du sein
il est fulgurant chez les gens qui sont
porteurs de ce gène le jour où
s'aperçoit c'est déjà trop tard c'est
aussi pour ça que j'ai accepté de
témoigner et de parler pour lui prouver
qu'aujourd'hui j'ai plus honte et que je
sais qu'elle en est capable aussi il
faut qu'elle le fasse il faut qu'elle le
fasse pour que on puisse être enfin
tranquille et qu'on stoppe cette chaîne
de malédiction de génération en général
votre grand-mère votre mère vous toutes
les femmes de la famille alors il y a
Lana votre fille qui a 9 ans un jour il
faudra lui dire la vérité cet ouvrage je
l'ai écrit parce que même si à la maison
ce n'est pas tabou et que elle se targue
de me dire que ma poitrine et mes seins
sont magnifiques parce qu'elle a vu que
cela c'est sa maman
je voulais laisser
toute cette explication au sein de ce
récit pour qu'elle puisse trouver aussi
la paix et surtout en moi parce qu'on
rêve tout en étant maman d'être aussi
des exemples qu'elle puisse se dire
voilà j'ai un modèle une solution
exemplaire de vie et qui me permettra si
je supporteuse de pallier et trouvez-moi
aussi la force de le faire
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu